[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je dis 18 avril bienvenue
dans le 7-8 journal de tv 78 tout de
suite les titres de cette édition
profité de la campagne des élections
européennes pour faire entendre ses
revendications à l'occasion du scrutin
du 26 mai prochain ufc que choisir fixe
cinq priorités pour les consommateurs
elle nous en parlons avec philippe
fleuret président de l'antenne locale de
l'association pour la région de
versailles
pâques c'est ce dimanche une fête
religieuse mais aussi une traditionnelle
chasse aux oeufs cette année la
confédération des chocolatiers lance une
opération solidaire pour les enfants
hospitalisés les personnes âgées
reportage dans une enseigne du mesnil
saint denis
et puis c'est un patrimoine en attente
de financement depuis 2014 le musée
d'art naïf de vie qui est fermé faute de
réhabilitation la commune se bat pour la
réouverture du site qui possède une
collection de huit cents toiles
découverte de ce trésor inexploités à la
fin de ce journal est les pompiers des
yvelines à l'elysée certains d'entre eux
ont été reçus aujourd'hui par emmanuel
macron le président de la république a
tenu à les mettre à l'honneur pour leur
action dans l'extinction de l'incendié
de notre dame de paris cette semaine 35
hommes 12 10 78 ont été envoyés à paris
dont le groupe d'intervention en milieu
périlleux
quatre fourgons incendie ont été
mobilisés et aussi deux bras élévateur
de 46 mètres de haut venant des casernes
de versailles et de magnanville elle est
plus haut et d'ile-de-france des
équipements qui ont eu une action est
déterminante dans la sauvegarde et du
beffroi nord de notre dame de paris
cette inauguration à la mi-journée sqy
ouest 16 25 et la mission locale de
saint quentin en yvelines ouvre de
locaux des locaux entièrement dédiée à
la garantie est jeune ils prennent place
dans le même bâtiment que l'antenne de
la mission locale à guyancourt la
garantie jeunes est un dispositif pour
les 18 25 ans sans emploi études ou
formation pendant un an un
accompagnement est assurée de manière
individuelle et collective avec une
pluralité d'expériences professionnelles
offertes aux jeunes une garantie de
ressources de 492 euros est versée aux
bénéficiaires est désormais le
dispositif dans l'agglomération sera
centralisé à guyancourt les propos sont
recueillis par nicolas landry
nous avons un ami sur le cac le premier
étage
et ce bâtiment était inoccupé la
garantie jeunes au niveau de saint
quentin en yvelines était suivie sur
différents pôles dans des unités un peu
contraint de ce bâtiment là étant
inoccupée j'ai demandé avec l'agglo et
la ville de guyancourt que je remercie
évidemment de voir comment on peut
orchestrer pour avoir ses locaux la donc
après quelques mois de tractations nous
avons obtenu ces locaux inoccupés
on les a transformés donc on a deux
salles de formation et des sables dédié
pour des entretiens individuels et dans
l'actualité un homme de 48 ans abattu
par la police à versailles les faits se
sont produits la nuit dernière vers
23h55 les forces de l'ordre sont appelés
rue mont boron par une femme son mari
l'individu en question venait de lui
adresser deux coups de couteau sur place
le forcené est agressif et menacé les
fonctionnaires avec un couteau après
plusieurs sommations les agents ouvrent
le feu et touche à deux reprises l'homme
il mourra des suites de ses blessures
les jours de son épouse
eux ne sont pas en danger une enquête va
être menée par l'igpn pour déterminer si
les policiers ont bien agi sous le coup
de la légitime défense
la ministre de la justice nicole
belloubet tête hier après-midi à la
maison centrale de poissy elle est venue
constater sur place l'effondrement d'un
mur d'enceinte intervenue le 28 mars
dernier est l'occasion d'évoquer à
l'avenir du site et de son déplacement
ou non en dehors du centre-ville
reportage de michael et demi d'euros et
de nicolas landry nicole belloubet en
visite à la maison centrale de poissy la
ministre de la justice est venu
constater l'effondrement d'un mur
extérieur de la présence survenu le 28
mars dernier
mesurée évidemment les inquiétudes qui
peuvent être celle de la population
quand vous avez un mur d'une prison qui
s'écroule
il y à de véritables inquiétudes que je
comprends bien et surtout envisagé avec
monsieur le maire l'avenir l'avenir pour
la ministre passe par une rénovation du
site la femme politique propose de
débloquer une enveloppe d'environ 60
millions d'euros
moi il me sens vraiment nécessaire si
nous restons à poissy au centre ville
comme je le souhaite que nous nous
engagions pour la ville et pour les
habitants de cette ville à rénover
complètement ces lieux
et à en faire vraiment une prison
moderne secure avec des objectifs clairs
de détention de son côté le maire de la
commune karl olive propose une
alternative déplacer la prison une
consultation citoyenne devrait être
lancé auprès des habitants de la commune
la question qui sera posée c'est
êtes-vous non favorables au maintien de
la maison centrale en centre ville
je souhaite le faire d'ici le mois de
juin dans une forme juridique que nous
sur laquelle nous travaillons et qui
sera évidemment autorisé la maison
centrale de poissy est installé en
centre ville depuis 1821 il compte
aujourd'hui 193 détenus dont 35 à
perpétuité les élections européennes se
dérouleront en france le 26 mai prochain
il n'y a pas que les candidats qui mène
campagne les consommateurs eux aussi se
mobilise pour faire entendre leur voix
en vue du scrutin bonsoir philippe le
ray soir vous êtes le président d'ufc
que choisir région de versailles
l'antenne locale de l'association de
défense des consommateurs alors ufc que
choisir à l'occasion de ces européenne
fixe cinq priorités pour la prochaine
mandature au parlement européen on va en
parler dans un instant d'abord rappelons
que l'association se mobilise à chaque
élection ça c'est une volonté de votre
part
oui c'est un moyen de défendre les
consommateurs avant chaque grande
élection se sont européennes ou
nationales présidentielle législatives
ont fait toujours par aux candidats à
tous les candidats des sous et que l'on
se soit voix retranscrit dans la loi et
donc on les contacte tous et est donc en
fait part de nos frais alors pour le
coup là les eurodéputés votent des
textes de lois qui ont une influence
directe sur la vie quotidienne des
consommateurs notamment sur leurs droits
face et des produits et des services qui
ont libre circulation dans l'espace
schengen comment l'association agite l
eau au niveau européen elle agit par
l'intermédiaire de ce qu'on appelle le
bug c'est à dire le beurre le bureau
européen des unions de consommateurs
donc qu'il faut à bruxelles auquel
adhèrent les principales organisations
de consommateurs européennes et donc ce
bureau se comporte comme un groupe de
pression sur elle
l'exercent des actions de lobbying
auprès des parlementaires européens
donc c'est un bureau et des unions de
consommateurs vous le disiez ça réunit
plusieurs associations finalement au
niveau européen des associations deux
autres pays qui à la demande portugaise
italienne et bien sûr et quels sont
justement les grands objectifs
alors que qui guide l'action du bugue et
du ufc que choisir aussi au niveau
européen
ces grandes directions alors les actions
sur des actions par exemple qui consista
à plus d'information des consommateurs
ce qu'il y ait plus de transparence dans
le domaine aussi par exemple donc je
vais essayer d'aider des exemples dans
le domaine des communications il y a eu
par exemple ou quand la dernière
mandature la possibilité donc qui a été
reconnue donc pour tous le consommateur
lorsque d'utiliser leur forfait
lorsqu'ils sont en déplacement à
l'étranger ou d'une suppression des
frais d'itinérance à cette différence
voilà dans le domaine aérien des
transports aériens la réglementation été
uniformisé entre les différents pays
lorsqu'il ya par exemple perte de deux
valises retard des moyens transports
donc ça y est dans libération qui
européenne m'appelant à quelle que soit
la compagnie plan que l'on prenne voilà
le droit de rétractation par exemple est
passée à 14 jours pour l'ensemble des
pays européens lorsqu'on fait des achats
et puis il ya aussi des choses on n'est
pas satisfait les principales avancées
sur les défaillances de la précédente
mandature
quels sont les points qui posent
problème aux problèmes et par exemple il
ya eu quelque chose qui était très
repris par la presse c'est l'histoire du
glyphosate c'est à dire les produits
toxiques et donc les voilà et donc on
n'a pas réussi donc il ya comme une
avancée en ce sens que la définition des
produits toxiques a été fait au niveau
des
ils parlement européen par contre
l'interdiction du diffuseur de l'europe
ça ça peut être obtenu également ici est
déposée aujourd'hui on n'a pas encore de
date définie ressorti de l'utilisation
du glyphosate cinq ans et qui avait été
prévu et ça ça n'a pas été retenu voilà
et puis des différents scandales que
tout le monde connaît par exemple que
l'on parle des lasagnes à la viande de
cheval des oeuvres qui prône il dédie sa
de diesel pour reçoit gala ou de ce
cadre de cap a déjà 20 danny care par
exemple c'est pas mal de scandales en
tout cas qui ont posé problème pour
cette mandature alors la prochaine
mandature c'est jusqu'en 2024
ufc que choisir avec les autres membres
du bug on définit cinq priorités pour
les consommateurs sur lesquels vous
appelez finalement les futurs
législateur européen c'est ça voilà on
les appelle intervenir sachant qu' il
faut savoir que dans le droit français
il ya environ 70% de du droit français
l'allée des lois et règlements qui sont
issus qui sont des transposition des
directives européennes
donc c'est pour ça que c'est aux
attentes de faire voter donc au niveau
européen quelles sont ses cinq priorités
alors l'es5 présenter sur la liste
suivante il y à tous rappelle les
produits l'obsolescence programmée ainsi
de garder des produits qui sont
fabriqués avec une durée de vie prévue
donc on demande à ce que déjà une
information précise au niveau des
consommateurs que les produits qui veut
dire est plus longtemps ils soient
maintenues sur le marché plus longtemps
et que les garanties par exemple sur 148
2 ans il produit peut durer 10 ans 15
ans que les garanties soient plus longue
qui c'est pas la peine de mettre
seulement deux ans vraiment promouvant
des produits plus durables et plus
durable et une bonne information sa ses
premiers points
il ya ce qu'on appelle l'affichage
nutritionnelle c'est à dire sur tous les
produits alimentaires
il ya un code couleur qui existe déjà
lui demander ce qu un triste score voilà
donc abcde avec des couleurs qui vont de
vert jaune orange rouge voilà on demande
que cela soit étendue au niveau européen
donc ce qui évite d
et des consommateurs par exemple de voix
de mal consommé de cette période du têt
grenot visité par exemple il ya
également une position sur les
médicaments qu'ils soient accessibles à
des prix plus abordables les we can oui
parce que actuellement les médicaments
donc des molécules sur fabriqués sur un
chinois he man ou les aux états unis et
pour les médicaments de pointe par
exemple on se retrouve avec des
médicaments qui sont fabriquées aux
états unis mais qui sont à des coûts
très très élevé très très élevé et les
les français par exemple au prince les
procurer parce que ça nous a beaucoup
trop cher tout à l'heure aussi du
glyphosate vous demander un encadrement
plus strict des produits chimiques
oui tu as vraiment plus strict des
produits chimiques parce que il ya eu
par exemple saman des décisions de
justice et on est et on voit par exemple
des boues sont au pouvoir donner le site
et qui a été condamné dans ton demande
que ce soit strictement à cadrer mais
enfin la dernière proposition c'est
développer une intelligence artificielle
plus éthique et voila voila plus éthique
c'est le temps oui parce que on
s'aperçoit que maintenant grâce aux
données très importantes qui sont
fournies par les dates à des décisions
peuvent être prises à l'insu des
consommateurs
il ya des décisions qui peuvent être
prises par exemple dans le domaine du
crédit en fonction de votre profil de ce
que vous êtes vous pouvez voir tel type
de crédit est potes othello et c'est un
exemple je compte bien d'autre donc je
vais cinq priorités fixées où vous
l'avez dit vous avez déjà sollicité les
candidats une quinzaine de candidats qui
sont déjà déclarés pour ces élections
européennes en france merci
il pleurait n'est ce pas c'est sur ce
plateau président du ufc que choisir
région de versailles toutes les
informations sur les différents sites
internet qui se sont affichées durant
cet entretien le manque de sommeil mal
de dos les salariés du secteur des
transports connaissent de nombreux
problèmes de santé mais il reste peu
sensibilisés alors pour lutter contre ce
problème leur complémentaire santé a
organisé une tournée dans toute la
france point d'étape à trappes avec
calypso vanier une tournée pour
améliorer la prévention santé dans les
transports routiers
c'est l'objectif du plan
transportez-vous bien se calment se rend
directement sur les lieux de travail des
employés comme ici à trappes pour ces
salariés se faire ausculter
d'être un réflexe tout simplement par
manque de temps et car ils sont
forcément sur les routes et que pour eux
aller voir chez nous aller voir un
médecin c'est pas forcément quelque
chose qui font régulièrement
selon une récente étude réalisée par
l'ifop 53 % des salariés du secteur
disent n'avoir aucune action prévention
dans leur entreprise
pourtant ces habitués de la route
rencontre de nombreux problèmes de santé
le dos un an d'arrêt 1 en deux mi temps
thérapeutique et là ça va faire un an je
suis je suis j'ai repris dans le temps
complet
c'est porter des charges lourdes
conduire toute la journée tout ce qui
est lié au travail de transport de
marchandises les bras a les épaules
physique quoi l'enjeu de cette tournée
mieux faire connaître les actions de
prévention et des services
d'accompagnement mises en place par leur
complémentaire santé
la déformation qui sont adaptés pour eux
sur la qualité pour évaluer leur qualité
de sommeil pour évaluer leur risque
cardiovasculaire diabète
cette tournée a duré deux mois 40
entreprises ont joué le jeu sur tout le
territoire français
le gym en trois avant la traditionnelle
chasse aux oeufs de pâques dans les
chocolateries tout est prêt et cette
année la confédération des chocolatiers
confiseurs de france lance même une
opération solidaire avec les enfants
hospitalisés et les personnes âgées
marylène yapi chinois
dans la chocolaterie du mix en unis la
penzé poussins ont investi la vitrine
depuis un mois et pour les derniers
préparatifs de pâques les livraisons
s'enchaînent
là forcément pour un peu choqué parce
qu'à un moment on va être un peu
submergé donc on a intérêt à en mettre
un peu en avance dans les commerces
rien n'est laissé au hasard dans la
présentation quand on n'est pas de ceux
qui ont regardé ce que ça donne
alors moi j'ai coupé des gobelets et
j'ai fait des simples parce que pâques
c'est aussi l'occasion de laisser
s'exprimer sa créativité
mon chef s'appelle nicolas morin a
proposé un sujet qui s'appelle l'offre
ou la cloche
mais ici le chocolat se veut aussi
généreux membres de la confédération des
chocolatiers confiseurs de france
christophe bertrand a fait un constat
simple les chocolatiers pour être sûr de
ne pas manquer prévoit large quitte à
rester avec des stocks de chocolat sur
les bras une fois pas que passer très
deux solutions soit on défait les
sachets en remet le chocolat au fond
noir et on va récupérer peut-être 20 kg
de marchandises soit à peu près 200
euros de marchandise ou alors avec ses
20 kg de marchandises qui représentaient
200 sujets ont fait plaisir à 200
personnes cette année les six boutiques
de l'aréna fried participent à
l'opération généreuse pâques
au total ils sont 160 chocolatier à
s'investir dans toute la france donc
l'idée qu'on a déterminés c'est dire aux
gens si vous voulez offrir un sujet un
enfant qui est hospitalisé pour vannes
ou se charger de l'offrir à ses hôpitaux
et on mettra en plus pour chaque sujet
offert un sujet que nous offrirons
et puis à la fin de toute façon on va
ouvrir également ce qui va nous rester
des partenariats sont aussi réalisées
avec des ehpad pour ne pas oublier les
personnes âgées la générosité du
chocolat trouve ici tout son sens
c'est un geste également de solidarité
qui peut sauver des vies le don du sang
une collecte est organisée ce samedi à
versailles c'est de 10 heures à 15
heures à la rotonde un don du sang un
peu particulier car il sera gastronomes
pour en parler julien chasse traduit un
bon soir bon ça vous êtes le vice
président de la table ronde française de
versailles qui organise ce don du sang
et gastronomes c'est la deuxième édition
dans la cité royale
alors avant d'en parler parlons déjà de
la table ronde française qu'est ce que
la table ronde jusqu'à un club actions
tournées dans l'associatif qui a été
créée en 1927 en angleterre et en 1950
qui arrivait en france et fait partie du
quota lagord qui regroupe quatre clubs
donc la table ronde française c'est un
club de jeunes hommes de moins de 40 ans
il ya le ladies circle des jeunes de
femmes de - 45 ans le club 41 d'hommes
de plus de 40 ans et le l'agora de
femmes depuis 35 ans et quels sont ses
buts justement justement c'est un club
associative tourné vers l'action donc
qu'elles soient culturelles humanitaires
sportif
donc après chaque club est libre de
choisir l'action qui venait donc en
france on a 200 soit en mode et trois
mouvements
et après au niveau national on est on à
sociaux nains actions au niveau national
qui s'appelle les voiles de l'espoir qui
a lieu tous les deux ans et qui a lieu
par exemple pour cet été aux entre le 15
et 22 juin en corse qui on emmène des
enfants en rémission de pardon rémission
de de cancer ou de leucémie ferrand une
semaine de voile d'accord alors vous
disiez ses parties de l'angleterre seule
ce réseau des tables rondes c'est à dire
c'est un réseau international
yalaoui y en a partout dans le monde en
fait c'était faire l'angleterre par un
ancien du rotary ben jeunes quitter au
rotary et en fait on a peu partout dans
le monde parce qu en afrique du sud eux
sur suisse suède de n'importe où en
france vous disiez c'est arrivé en 1950
est précisément pour la table deux
rondes de versailles c'est c'est la
numéro 6
si je ne m'abuse et c'est l'une des plus
anciennes en fait on leur fait plus le
numéro est faible plus la table ronde et
ancien donc la carie a été écrit en
premier c'est une loin et après ils sont
venus versailles en 6 ça fait 60 54 9 en
existe à versailles et du coup derrière
d'autres se créent une 015 clémente et
combien d'hommes la composent
aujourd'hui ça serait du cas de
versailles il a ce talent de marseillan
nous sommes aux six 6 membres actifs et
vous disiez ce sont des hommes de moins
de 40 ans voilà et le genre d'actions
que vous y développer alors on va parler
dans un instant de ce don du sang
gastronomes et quel type d'action vous
venez de versailles
ça peut être cette année on a fait
l'assistant du séminaire temps de
rambouillet on a tenu un point
kilométrique
on a fait des dons de livres à l'hôpital
mignot au service pédiatrique donc on a
déjà fait aussi des dons à baby foot on
allait réussir à réunir des fonds pour
acheter un bel foot pour le service
pédiatrique de l'hôpital mignot donc
après c'est peut être variés comme
emmener des enfants placés dans les
maisons spécialisées voir des matchs de
rugby ça s'appelle l'ovale de l'espoir
où tout aux petites actions que l'on
veut faire
donc cette action là c'est le don du
sang gastronomes qui se déroule ce
samedi à la rotonde à versailles c'est
la deuxième édition c'est quoi le
principe du don du sang gastronomare en
principe c'est d'aider le fs donc l'état
plomberie français du sang du sang comme
il ya toujours beaucoup de demandes en
fait là on est dans une période où il ya
des ponts comme pike est en fait le don
du sang quatre hommes s'est en fait
envie d'avoir une collation comme les
sens du style donne habituellement la
nounou ont fait venir un traiteur et on
aura des verrines des petits fours
pourra manger un peu pour la collation
donc ça permet d'aider les gens de
motiver à vrai dire les gens d'aller
zapater pour venir à les faire venir et
nous derrière nous faire connaître dans
la ville de versailles donc avoir
finalement ddb de haut standing voilà
changé que habituellement le don du sang
on sait ils sont primordiaux les dons du
sang pour sauver des vies venir en aide
aux malades d'autant plus que les
réserves de son sont en baisse et les
produits sanguins ont aussi une durée de
vie limitée ça c'est une thématique qui
est cher
la table ronde de versailles en fait
c'est ils ne venaient plus beau club
organise maintenant dans le sens
gastronomes donc après ça peut être nous
s'est attaché à sa puis après ça peut
varier en fonction nous fait un traiteur
par exemple d'autres clubs font venir
des cuisiniers d'autres lycées hôteliers
donc après peu importe tant avec ses
idées ont fait l'action donc le principe
qu'on donne son sang et ont peu profité
ensuite de ce buffet qui est proposé par
le traiteur ça va se dérouler comme ça
donc après c'est entre 10 heures et 15
heures à la rotonde si juste à côté de
la gare rive gauche et en reçu en fait
il ya une salle juste à l'entrée du côté
du parking du saut par an
et oui vous pouvez vous aider votre sang
et après vous profitez aussi participer
il faut il faut s'inscrire d'avançon
peut donner directement quand vous
voulez danser ouvert de 10h à 15h donc
vous passez vous donnez votre sang et
vous repartez apprennent à manger au
buffet je rappelle ce rendez-vous don du
sang gastronomes au programme ce samedi
20 avril à versailles c'est de 10 heures
à 15 heures à la rotonde merci julien
chat stranieri vice président de la
table ronde française de versailles
c'est un trésor malheureusement
inexploitées dans le village de vic
depuis 2014 un musée d'art naïf attend
des financements pour pouvoir être
réhabilité est rouvert au public son
maire a ouvert
justement les portes et l'histoire de ce
lieu à marylène iapichino
à
[Musique]
dans le village de vic situé au centre
des yvelines
un panneau nous l'annoncent dès l'entrée
ici se trouve au musée d'art naïf
seulement depuis 2014 il est fermé donc
on a tendance qui était dans le temps
elle accueille aujourd'hui bon bah oui
là c'est encore fermés puisque les
travaux sont pas sont pas tout à fait
finie donner à la commune il ya 20 ans
le musée sur cet art des autodidactes et
gérée par plusieurs associations
successives
quand la dernière abandonne son
administration vient à la mairie qui
décide de fermer pour mieux réouvrir
après rénovation donc là on rentre dans
la partie qui était ouverte au musée
donc on voit les toiles qui sont encore
qu'il faut encore accrocher une
collection de 800 toile d'or sur les
murs ou dans les emballages à laquelle
s'ajoutent les oeuvres de la défunte
propriétaire des lieux c'est la vue de
la route qui qui est en dessous du musée
avec les deux faces net
elle a fait ça de sa fenêtre le pari fou
d'un collectionneur et de sa femme qui
rachète ce qui était alors une ferme
pour la transformer en musée
et là on se trouve dans ce qui devait
être l'étape puisqu'on retrouve ici les
auges à vache avec les chaînes qui
étaient là pour attacher les les animaux
et l'os pour pour manger le musée d'art
naïf de vic est inaugurée en 1973 la
collection de max fourni contient 1500
pièces réparties entre le musée de vic
et là elle s'enquiert à paris
aujourd'hui tout repose entre un musée
fermé et le sous sol de la halle caché
au public
objectif pour le maire rapatrier toutes
ces oeuvres ici et créer en plus une
salle dédiée à son épouse la pianiste
françoise est née lancé marié avec
monsieur max fournit la laisser tomber
le piano pour
ehrhart et repeinte puisque c'est ce
qu'a voulu faire dès le départ un énorme
projet de réhabilitation pour la commune
de 380 habitants passionnés par cette
histoire son maire est vrai même de la
raconter avec un espace visite dans les
parties privées où a vécu le couple
parce que c'est elle en étant jeune
peut-être oui on trouve un peu ses
traits j'ai toujours espoir puisque là
on on a à force de chercher des fonds
vont on en a trouvé un peu donc j'espère
qu'on va pouvoir
des mois de septembre arrivée à
continuer à reprendre des travaux il
reprend des travaux intérieurs première
victoire grâce à une aide du département
la réfection de la toiture tout juste
achevé dans la mairie de vic les plans
du futur musée sont prêts le projet a
été réfléchie et imaginé pour accueillir
le plus de visiteurs possible les
plantes effet le permis de construire a
été déposé et accepté
donc tout est prêt pour démarrer il
manque
un peu le financement pour tout faire on
a on va avoir le financement pour
commencer les travaux
mais est ce qu'on pourra aller jusqu'au
bout pour l'instant c'est le point
d'interrogation
un prêt qui s'élève tout de même à près
d'un million et demi d'euros sans
compter l'aménagement le maire garde
espoir de trouver des mécènes
on s'est pris au jeu et mat en bas on
aimerait bien le voir le voir
fonctionner c'est quand même
un bon sol de bataille de quoi s'occuper
pendant quelques années
avis aux amoureux de l'art naïf musée en
plus d'histoires recherche financement
ainsi que fin connaisseur pour en
organiser les expositions et puis ses
amis de longue date était de retour dans
les yvelines ben et arnaud tsamere ne se
quittent plus plateaux télé
collaboration avec des médias sportifs
et maintenant sur scène pour leur
spectacle à la ferme du manet de
montigny le bretonneux mélanie poker une
ferme du manei l'ars arriviez dans le
public mais aussi sur scène ben et
arnaud tsamere ont régalé leurs
spectateurs de leur humour absurde et
partager leur plaisir d'être ensemble
john quelles sont les conséquences du
bric site sur le quotidien des
britanniques ou à tahar ouattar zico nsi
queens of bricks ait fort for the basic
people in the life of all the day watts
parfois je suis très spectateurs de ben
quand on est sur scène et j'ai envie
j'ai envie de me marrer avec le public
parce qu'ils me fait rire faut un petit
peu lutter aussi contre ça pour pas que
ça devienne juste de dollars de pots de
queyries alors tu paies une place ou
alors j'ai pas dans le public du coup
c'est de faire du monde un spectacle
crescendo à l'humour de plus en plus
loufoques ben est un autre sa mère forme
lors du ou en 2013 dans on n'demande
qu'à en rire de la télé à la scène à ses
créations leur semblait évidente
je sais pas si les gens s'attendaient
tellement à ce qu'on fasse un truc
ensemble mais nous
la pression coeur oui on en parlait
depuis longtemps quoi voilà c'était
enfin bref c'était surtout pour nous de
dire enfin sur scène parce qu'on a nous
deux c'est vraiment une envie après
avoir fait beaucoup de cash à la t&d
disgression de l'improvisation les
artistes font de chaque représentation
une création inédite
ben est un autre sa mère sont en tournée
jusqu'au mois de juin et je pense à tous
ces jeunes du lycée pour regarder on
pourra regarder c'est la fin de cette
édition replay et reportages à retrouver
sur notre application mobile et notre
site internet dans un instant le 7-8
loisirs avec marylène iapichino pour
faire le plein d'idées de sorties en ce
week end prolongé de pâques et le
journal lui revient être dès mardi pour
une édition en direct à 18h sur tv 78
très belle soirée à tous
[Musique]
non